you have the numbers 1 to 9 and you need  to arrange them in a 3x3 grid so every  row column and diagonal has the same sum  how do you do it ancient chinese  mathematicians had a wonderful  construction called the low shoe  technique write the numbers in a grid  rotate them and expand  swap the corners  and compress back into a square  now every row column and diagonal has  the same sum of fifteen  wow  magic squares have fascinated  mathematicians for thousands of years  and they are inspiring current research  too scientists in india have proposed  using magic square arrangements to  reconfigure solar panels so they are  more efficient and can handle partial  shading better it is amazing that an  ancient math puzzle might shape our  future energy needs and for that reason  it really is a magic square